washing your hands with soap is possibly
the simplest way to flush pathogens down
the drain soap molecules can interact
with pathogens such as coronavirus
leading to their destruction
each soap molecule has two parts the
head is hydrophilic which means it likes
to interact with water while the lipid
tail is hydrophobic which means it wants
to get away from water to find similar
water avoiding particles
this is the basis of how soap works when
soap molecules encounter lipid particles
on our skin the tails aggregate around
them to form spherical structures called
micelles creating a water free
environment
similar things happen when they
encounter enveloped viruses such as
corona virus enveloped viruses carry
their genome and supporting proteins
inside of lipid bilayer membrane with
the proteins necessary for infection
embedded in the membrane
in cells and viruses these lipids are
packed neatly into two sheets with lipid
tails facing inward
the lipid ends of the soap molecules are
attracted to the lipids in the membrane
they take advantage of the presence of
membrane proteins which can perturb the
neatly organized bilayer to insert
themselves into the viral membrane
if there is only a small amount of soap
the soap molecules only loosen the
membrane but with more soap they begin
to create my cells around membrane
lipids
they are also attracted to hydrophobic
amino acids in the membrane proteins
extracting them from the membrane the
structural integrity of a virus is
essential for infection
so washing your hands with soap protects
you better from infection than washing
with only water and the log you lather
the higher your chance of destroying the
virus